that's what it's like being a woman
anyways like half the time it's like I
feel great not gonna lie so I work with
a bunch of men right I literally and the
only female that travels with about
thirty guys when I do NFL games and
sometimes your work in a game when your
ovaries are hurting right it's a great I
love being a girl let's celebrate
international girl she's 32 yard field
goal yes please and I'll be honest there
are some guys in the NFL that would like
hope they make anyway how did you become
interested in sports I always ask my
friends though yeah cuz of my dad my
dad's a great storyteller he's on
television and he would tell me all
about players and like what players
liked each other and what players didn't
like each other and what coaches had
been with what teams and he was just a
good good storyteller so I've been he
trained that way yeah and so I decided
at an early age I was gonna do it for a
living that's a really cool story not so
much when I was that like dad hey Larry
Bird and Magic Johnson and Kevin McHale
his favorite was when I was in the aisle
of the grocery store and I was like dad
what's that it's like a tampon you know
any time well let's have mom tell you
we're gonna get home you know what I'm
gonna cover sport yeah got that so what
advice do you have for girls trying to
you know break into a male-dominated
field yeah I mean I think no matter if
you're trying to be a sports broadcaster
or you're trying to do anything else
which really seems all male-dominated at
this point um I just say work really
hard and another one which I mean I know
you and I can relate to is have thick
skin which I'm still trying to work on
but the unfortunate part and Kelly knows
this about being in the public eye is
everybody has an opinion and they can
say it and they can post it on your
Instagram and they can be living with
their mom at 50 years old and they're
big
season it and still have a fun and
pinyon and yeah it's taken me a long
time to try to have thick skin I think
I'm really doing a lot better about it
than I used to I feel like when you're
in your 20s and your 30s you're like
stop you're really hurting my feelings
I'm in my 40s now and I'm like you know
why like I'm not doing it for you anyway
so yeah huge sports fan obviously and I
can get into this part of sport yeah and
you can I I'm just somebody that like
let's be honest I'm not a fashion icon I
mean I'm more of a tomboy I like to be
comfortable yeah I mean that's just my
jam I wear a ballroom gown and Dancing
with the Stars I wear a comfortable
clothes on the sideline something in
between but I felt like there was a real
white space in the team apparel area for
women I just felt like women weren't
being catered to there weren't many
options out there and I'm a die-hard fan
but I don't need the team logos
splattered across my chest yeah just a
fun fashionable way to kind of cheer for
your team and then I just felt like
sizes are very hard to deal with we're
excited because we have sizes yes
absolutely and who by the way once you
know to feel uncomfortable you want to
be feeling great looking great and
cheering for your team at the same time
in sports my nickname is EA so that you
know throw down to the field and EA is
there so we created a line called where
he spelled it with the EA and our whole
slogan is you can wear it anywhere and
everywhere well audience members
Veronica and Jenny are representing our
two teams here in LA ladies can you
stand up let's talk about love you just
got married right two years yeah that's
the newlywed situation oh I got together
stay together yeah so he's retired
hockey player I don't know how to skate
whatsoever so basically I'm saying
there's a camera on me if you let go of
me I will kill you
his family was all there waiting for me
to eat it but it was fine
do you love marriage that was it good
yeah it's fine others I don't yeah
seems like it's working out just fine I
mean right now with my schedule with
football and and he's working with the
Los Angeles Kings yeah we're kind of we
were kind of out the only thing we
really discussed to March is when is our
did our dog go to the bathroom I I know
you have kids we're working on it but
it's like right now with the dog it's
like oh my god soup and your entire life
it's like did he poop today yeah we
didn't poop today was he gonna poop
tomorrow I mean yeah I'm gonna text my
mom and ask oh if it's a big deal it is
worse when it's the children especially
boys you walk in and you're like oh you
played in it cool it's in every crevice
of your crib probably in your mouth yeah
and then you just cry Aaron you Dutch
you just cry so don't take that back
we're not gonna all right wait switching
gears from foo you were know this is
actually more series and I and my family
has been highly affected by cervical
cancer and you were actually diagnosed
in 2016 right so I guess my question is
you're you're fine now right and right
now and how did you find out just
honestly thank you regular annual exam I
mean right before I go to football
season every year it's like going back
to school when your mom would like get
your teeth checked now it's like you go
to the doctor go to the gyno get the
extensions done get the roots yeah and
all that and they really yeah week three
of the football season that year got a
text and you know when you get a text
from a gyno on a Saturday it's not good
so yeah wheels went into motion I ended
up having to cervical cancer surgeries
there was a little bit of a concern that
I was gonna have to have a hysterectomy
but not able or not I did not have to
have that thank God I had that happened
with a friend and I may I always follow
my friends I'm like get your eggs first
before you doing cuz you can't after
radiation oh yeah yeah and that was a
big thing for us like before we had this
second surgery when the first one didn't
work there was a big conversation we did
we've done all that stuff but you have
to you doctors better don't mention that
because they're so concerned about the
cancer I was right intent about the
patient but that's an important thing
women and children yeah and even more
important I mean again there's no
symptoms with cervical cancer I was fine
I remember when we first got the test
results back I remember telling some of
my friends and they're like you're fine
you work out all the time
you eat right you're in great shape and
it was like it has nothing that was
literally high next point I was gonna
say and you're a picture of health and
it can happen to anyone and you really
should get regular check and again
because there aren't any symptoms of it
and I just found it on an annual exam
and even worse not to scare everybody
and get them on WebMD right now but I
was going every single year so it's not
like I was somebody that missed my
annual I was going every single year and
then I had friends after I came out and
I revealed that I had had it I said oh
my god I haven't been in three years I'm
like would you you need to go to the
doctor like you just have to go and get
checked because much like prostate
cancer which my dad had you should not
die of cervical cancer it's curable and
it is detectable and you just need to go
to the doctor but the reason why the
rate is so alarming with ovarian and
cervical cancer is because it's and you
don't know you have yet so by the time
you know you have it you might be at
Stage four absolutely yeah that's why
it's after this call your doctor I mean
I'm so thankful for my oncologist and
everything and he is such a wonderful
good-looking man and I'm always so sad
that's how I see them every second
because I do I have to go every six
months now that's my checkup it is
horrible and then you go and they take
your blood pressure and they're like
your blood pressure is up I'm like oh
crap yeah yeah and then I leave and I go
eat a big fat doughnut and I go shopping
I'm like we deserve it and there's a new
twist on it which I actually love there
is a choice and I'd have if you all have
this on your show our judges can
actually save a dancer which is really
fun and exciting on this we do have a
say dude it's my favorite part don't you
feel that sometimes yeah and sometimes
it's like I've been that contestant in
that moment and it's like it all
accounts and sometimes you just have a
weird show or whatever people that
usually love you weren't home voting and
it's like well this person does not
deserve to go home right it gives you
that that chance you know ya know it's
very exciting I'm glad I'm not that
person because I just want to save
everyone oh but yeah it's it's awesome
that's why I love live TV so much
because anything can happen
it's like yeah I want you to see yeah
yeah I love live TV - I'm with you well
be sure to catch Aaron on the sidelines
for Fox and on Dancing with the Stars
Monday nights on ABC all here's where I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this